Dylan tell me about hedgehogs what's the
worry
um so hedgehogs are in very much a
decline in this country we've gone from
around 30 million the 1950s to estimated
less than 1 million today and there's a
lot we need to do to be able to help and
part of my job as a hedgehog Champion
through Hedgehog street is to try and
help people be more Hedgehog aware and
try and help hedgehogs in their own
garden love it
how do you become a hedgehog Champion so
that's something anyone can do through a
charity called Hedgehog Street which
does excellent work with Hedgehog
conservation work so anyone can do that
they can sign up they can just pledge to
help hedgehogs spread the word with
their friends family and neighbors and
do things like make a hedgehog highway
so that hedgehogs can get in and out of
your garden about 13 centimeter hole in
the fence which is really important okay
tell me about this particular head oh
should we sit down and you can tell me
about the Hedgehog there we go this is
about the size of a hedgehog that you
might see so yes this is this is one of
my nice size best model hedgehogs which
is quite nice so yes this is the
erinacea Sarah Pierce Hedgehog which
you'll find in this country and
obviously they are in very rapid decline
as I've mentioned so
um an excellent thing to do you could
put water out for hedgehogs as well
particularly this time of year they'll
be coming out of hibernation
early yeah so the weather's the
weather's varied a lot particularly in
March really hedgehogs normally come out
it tends to need to be about 10 degrees
or above full hedgehogs to come out
but actually because of the fluctuations
in temperature what that's meant is some
of them are coming out slightly earlier
when it's warmer or slightly later when
it's cooler but they have a lack of food
source and a lot of them come out of
hibernation quite dehydrated as well so
people could help by putting a shallow
dish of water out for hedgehogs and
what's the biggest threat to hedgehogs
um I would say there's been a lot of
number reasons for their decline in
numbers really but a lot of places you
know almost not really welcoming for
hedgehogs a lot of the landscape has
changed Gardens are quite manicured
there's lots of fencing and urbanization
and Paving so I think leaving a
patchable garden to grow wild as well
would be something to really help
because that would help encourage
hedgehogs and other Wildlife into your
garden so if I forget to mow the lawn
can I say I'm doing that for the
Hedgehogs absolutely absolutely don't
yeah leave that life actually your
garden to grow wild and you know really
help other other Wildlife as well okay
so what next for you and hedgehogs so my
next goal is to continue working on my b
Hedgehog aware Campaign which aims to
reduce gardening related injuries to
hedgehogs so I have made these be
Hedgehog wear stickers in fact oh show
me questions yeah there we go here so
these are and there's my logo here yeah
these are um stickers which just can be
put on the tape machine of course thank
you these are to be put on Garden
machinery and equipment particularly
strimmers to try and remind people just
to check for hedgehogs before work yeah
which is really important and they've
had some good work on this and I'm
partnering with some companies
um to move this forward and get these on
the production line of strummers and
mowers across the country